la pandémie nous a forcés à nous adapter
à une nouvelle réalité
le télétravail quel impact aura cette
expérience sur l'avenir des espaces à
bureaux des centres villes partout en
ville
les bureaux sont vides abandonnées et
sans vie jeudi sauf ça fait 8 morts quel
bureau et vivre des heures de moi je
prône lui même faire un taux tous nos
bureaux fermés c'est nous nos directrice
qui occupaient ces bureaux et elles sont
tous partis avec leurs pièces
équipements nécessaires au travail ça
c'est notre étage clients notre centre
de conférence est au 25e étage qui est
dédié seulement la réception de clients
elle est nulle surprise événements et
sociales et d'âge qu'on va laisser
tomber
rien ne prépare et les employeurs à ce
grand vide
dix mois plus tard ils se demandent ce
qui va advenir de ces espaces on avait
des idées de grandeur
aujourd'hui le monde a changé
simon de ben est à la tête d'une
entreprise en technologie 300 employés
c'est ici que les gens y viennent dîner
absolument qu'on a
en temps normal sont invités en janvier
passé y aurait eu des centaines de
personnes assis ensemble ici en train de
vendre entendu des rires des gens
discuter
ces bureaux sont flambant neuf un peu
moins deux cent mille pieds carrés que
son équipe occuper pleinement depuis
janvier 2020
un peu plus loin dans cette grande tour
du centre ville un grand cabinet
d'avocats à montréal vient de renouveler
son bail
cent trente mille pieds carrés 400
employés
on a signé une extension de bail pour 16
en deux semaines à val confinement qui
était dû à la commune
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la décision de
fermer toutes les entreprises et tous
les commerces du jour au lendemain les
bureaux se vivent environ 40 pour cent
des travailleurs au pays passe en mode
télétravail
du jamais vu chez m plan une agence de
communications médicales
la quarantaine d'employés travaillent
désormais à domicile
il fallait penser à faire des
modifications à ses plus petits sous
louer c'est toutes les questions qui me
sont passées par la tête
au moment d'investir quelques millions
dans ses bureaux neufs l'idée du tous
ensemble pour simon était la bonne on y
croyait on y croit encore on repense
procès c'est fini et oui le bureau fait
partie de notre identité énormément
on a vécu des moments extraordinaires
ici aujourd'hui le monde a changé
[Musique]
environ la moitié des travailleurs en
télétravail souhaite que cela se
poursuive au delà de la pandémie
souvent dans des formules hybrides entre
la maison et le bureau
non je vois le gros changement elles
viendront pas faire un 9 à 5
les employés vont venir deux à trois
jours par semaine au bureau il reste
envahie fait à la maison maintenant que
c'est possible d'effectuer probablement
la majorité des activités qu'on a fait
historiquement de le faire à distance
maintenant parce que la technologie
permet de le faire on est amené à se
poser la question oui mais pourquoi
débuts au pourquoi irions nous au bureau
l'architecturé l'aménagement des bureaux
sont tout à coup remis en question les
superficies qui vont être dégagées
potentiellement par ce travail et des
maisons est ce que les entreprises vont
décider de réduire la superficie ou tout
simplement d'adapter un peu plus les
lieux de travail pour faire en sorte
qu'ils gagnent en efficacité
quand la pandémie se déclare les plans
de réaménagement des bureaux de mccarthy
tétrault sont sur la planche à dessin
ça nous a emmenés à se reposer certaines
questions sur certaines certains des
éléments du projet leur bureau occupe
cinq étages dans la tour dont le 25e où
se trouve la réception et les salles de
conférence
c'est ce qu'est un aspect de prestige en
amérique du nord qui est associé avec la
hauteur on veut occuper soit le dernier
et aldo ou un des derniers étages du
tour du moins ça c'était le cas avant
les événements de la pandémie
un accès plus direct à la lutte devient
maintenant un avantage le transport
vertical une contrainte avant la coved
on pouvait se retrouver à plusieurs
personnes entassées dans un ascenseur
aujourd'hui haute
c'est des choses qui probablement ne
seront plus acceptés dans les nouveaux
plans revue par les architectes
l'accueil et les salles de conférences
du 25e sont ramenés plus bas à la
mezzanine
aujourd'hui on retransforme cet
espace-là de fond en comble pour en
faire un centre clients et pour nos
clients
le passeport un avantage indéniable à ne
pas avoir su apprendre ces ascenseurs là
et simplement rentrer dans nos espaces à
partir de la maisonnée ces dernières
années on a vu aussi une densification
des espaces de travail des travailleurs
côte à côte
parfois sans poste a signé des
environnements peu compatible avec la
distanciation physique mais chose
certaine ce que je pense qu'on va y voir
une tendance à des danses fils par
rapport à où on était juste avant la
pandémie
si c'est le cas le fait pas c'est une
portion du tenter dé travail aura pour
effet de réduire l'occupation de
l'espace cosmique les pieds carrés de
circulation la largeur des circulations
vont être bonifié donc ce ça peut amener
une dédensification de l'espace
mais là où l'expérience du travail à
domicile risque d'influencer le plus le
design des bureaux c'est sans doute le
niveau sonore
on a appris à travailler dans le silence
parce qu'on a besoin de réapprendre à
travailler dans un environnement où est
ce qu'il n'ya pas de distractions les
coups 6
c'était souvent la fin négliger le dans
l'équation l'an passé les panneaux
acoustiques était prévue dès fois bon
tomber dans un deuxième budget qui te
recoucher l'année d'après et puis ça me
faisait jamais donc l'acoustique
redevient maintenant vraiment un des
éléments clé de l'équation la pandémie
pourrait aussi donner au grand coup
d'accélérateur aux aménagements plus
souple avec moins d'éléments fixe c'est
ce qu'on intègre dans les nouveaux
espaces de mai car quitter trop alors
dans la zone verte que voyez ici ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on a aussi prévu des
mobiliers et donc des objets qui est non
seulement ce peuvent être déplacées
facilement dans l'espace mais peuvent
même eux mêmes chargés configuration
après autant mois passés au boulot chez
soi c'est sans doute aussi notre
relation avec le lieu de travail qui est
appelé à changer un lieu moins voué à la
production plus destiné à l'innovation
et à la socialisation
je pense que le milieu de travail va
devenir un endroit pour se
renner gizeh d'une certaine façon donc
on va travailler dans nos choses à la
maison et de retourner au bureau ça
avait quelque chose de spécial avec
quelque chose que mon bureau je pense
que le monde est en train de se
réorienter pour repositionner l'humain
au centre de tout ça et les humains que
nous sommes ont réalisé les bénéfices de
télétravail en termes d'autonomie de
mobilité et de gestion du temps tout en
réalisant qu'il y a des dimensions de
nos échanges personnels qui n'arrivent
pas à traverser l'écran on est vraiment
un groupe c'est serré c'est une équipe
et qui travaille beaucoup ensemble
mais de façon générale le social manque
pour tous
je pense qu'un certain point on se
prenaient pour acquis je pense qu'on se
voyait tous m'ont envoyé puis en même
temps ça faisait juste partie de notre
quotidien et le jour qu'on le perdu
c'est comme si le moment où est ce qu'on
a réalisé à quel point c'était important
pour nous simon de binh a pris la
décision en nous de donner le choix à
ses employés de revenir ou non au bureau
après la pandémie
il va sacrifier entre 30 et 50% son
espace oui il ya un peu un deuil à faire
et le deuil
le deuil pour - fr aujourd'hui on se
donne le droit de repenser notre
quotidien repenser nos outils
technologiques notre façon de colabor en
équipe
notre façon de vivre notre quotidien
comme travailleur de façon dirige une
entreprise on va perdre la vue mais on
va gagner en fonctionnalités
carlotta bac lui a fait le choix de
revoir l'aménagement de l'espace
qu'occupe le bureau et de rester
enracinée au centre-ville
moi je pense qu'elle centre-ville va
demeurer le poumon de la ville puis je
pense que les gens vont vouloir
retourner au centre-ville
donc je suis peut-être un optimiste à ce
niveau là mais je pense pas que on va
passer les 10 15 prochaines années à
travailler en pyjama la maison
peut-être pas en effet mais par contre
ce qui semble acquis c'est que la main
d'oeuvre sera dorénavant plus mobile et
virtuels que jamais